[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Jason seaman teacher by day football
coach by night on May 25th 2018 he
stopped the school shooting in his
seventh grade science class first off as
a person who isn't looking for attention
nor entirely comfortable with the
situation I'm currently in the scariest
15 seconds of his life became his 15
minutes of fame my actions on that day
in my mind were the only acceptable
actions I could have done given
circumstances a quick-thinking science
teacher is being credited with saving
lives heroically confining the student
just about everybody who's ever met him
has come out of the woodwork now Raimi
came up with the idea to start a
GoFundMe page serving as the honorary
chairperson of the Indiana Derby honor
tonight at the Pacers season opener gave
Jason seaman a new car
president Trump praised
in Indiana teacher for stopping a school
shooting Chicago cop invited Cena to
come up to date now has a beer named
after him not one to seek the spotlight
today science teacher Jason seaman
couldn't avoid being the center of
attention in Noblesville ever since he's
become the biggest hero in town
even in our district that is the most
awkward thing for me because I don't
feel I did anything special there's a
kid and kids in need of help and to be
told you're somebody special for helping
a kid is absurd to me
[Music]
everybody in here wants to pay for my
meal
that's kind of crazy to think about if I
look around I see three or four faces I
actually know I go to a restaurant
expecting to pay for my own food wanting
to pay the way
they don't let me
that's weird
no Michelle is a typical Midwest County
seat we are in a very very tough League
but they're doing well we have young
coach he's well respected whenever they
get out here and just relax they're at
their best because they have so much
pressure and stress to be in middle
school when they can put all that in the
rearview and just have fun and play
they're all smiles you can see it and
they're getting after it I teach seventh
grade science and Nobles at West middle
school and I Koshi eighth grade football
team you guys are my smelliest if you
take my first year teaching it was a
rocky road I was learning as I was going
and then I started to develop my
classroom personality and that continues
to change and evolve I try not to let
the shooting affect it
coaching it definitely has so I always
tried to keep you know this barrier
between myself and the players and I can
definitely tell that this year is just
different because Noblesville has a lot
of positives going for it just one dark
cloud that's kind of still hovering a
little bit is this really who we want to
be a country where anybody at any time
could be shot to death it's happened
again here in the United States that
school shooting one student has been
injured two students were shot gunshot
wounds two 15 year olds dead it happened
in the hallway the bullet came from a
room
des dormer fired a gun in his classroom
there have been 23 school shootings
where someone was hurt or killed so far
this year Wake Forest University of
Lincoln High School Santa Fe High School
Huffman High School Italy high school
Stoney's high school Forest High School
the list goes on and on and on and it
wasn't even Junior
of course you know all those shootings I
mean we hear him and you just you don't
think it's not gonna happen in little
elbows up well it did it we have
breaking news breaking news from Indiana
no another school shooting this morning
take a deep breath with me on this one
we have breaking news in the state of
Indiana there has been a shooting at
Noblesville West middle school just one
of those days where people were gonna
show up we were gonna take the test and
that would be that and going to the
weekend and first hour went by fine and
second hours when everything went down
the preliminary information is that a
male student asked to be excused from
his class he left to use the restroom
and he came back and my friend opened
the door for him he did come in first of
all in 10 seconds as soon as he came in
shots are fired the 7th grader was armed
with a pair of handguns he did shoot the
teacher in the process as well as a
female student who is in critical
condition I thought I would hit the
floor
you know I don't have an astonishing
like nobody was standing like getting
down the first sign that something was
off was the pressure I felt with my
abdomen which was the first move and
that's when I saw we just made eye
contact and he was pointing his weapon
straight at me that's kind of where it
just clicked no I acted I had a
basketball in my hand I reared back and
I threw it I threw it at him and it made
him have to move and that changed his
aim point and then I just tackled him to
the ground and told my students to get
out of there we all I got out simply
quit I think that that time where they
reality kicked in for me we're now
learning how quickly the situation was
contained authorities are swarming the
scene students escorted on buses out to
safety all yet seen a safe shooter at
Hancock
virtually all school shootings occur in
under five minutes to get through this
quick and they get it stopped and get
him identified and down clearly save
lives Jason was a defensive lineman in
the Illinois College big guy you know
because of that perhaps it was more
instinctive to just tackle this kid you
know and get him down and obviously he
did that I don't know if it's the
product being in contact sports I mean I
was in wrestling how was it football
basketball the way I played it with a
contact sport
I don't know I've just always been a
reactive person I don't know I didn't
think about it I didn't make a choice it
was just what I did I'm a person of
action
it's easy to say that you would put
yourself out there and protect a kid but
it's another thing to do it even after
being shot he still came back and did
football with us he's really open and
he's just like a great person it's just
amazing what coach seaman did an amazing
coach an amazing person he's just a good
guy and I appreciate him being my coach
yes I think he's a hero hero is always a
weird word for me
I think anytime a situation is intense
and a good person does the right thing
they don't feel like they should be
recognized for it because they were just
doing the right thing Jason is the
humble hero he doesn't want the
spotlight but let's be real he took
three bullets his student Ella Whistler
took seven both of them are already back
at school with bullets still in their
bodies I had Ella all year
she's a showman at heart she loves to
sing she loves his dance she loves to
just have fun in that regard I think
that was one of the hardest parts for me
because I knew about her injuries and I
wondered if she'd get back to that the
clavicle is shattered her first second
rib was fractured and her c5 and c6 was
was fractured so it all affected the
nerve damage on her whole right arm my
physical therapist is like working on my
shoulder cuz all my muscles are tight
instead of trying to loosen him up and
the occupation was working on my hand
and arm or any of my arms straight in my
hand back to 100% function there's a
chance that my hand will get back to
100% yeah you remember what else we're
always worried about has the bullet
moved then bullet moves closer to your
spinal cord I mean the debate on
firearms is always going to rage on
because it's a personal opinion and when
people get into personal opinions
there's never a winner there's no common
ground because everybody wants to win do
I think putting more guns in the school
will help solve the problem probably not
I've only experienced what happened to
me I think we have to treat each other
better
want to get at the heart of the problem
and that is a whole different ballgame
tonight to pay tribute to the men you
love gave selflessly on May 25th and the
following weeks today noble Phil says
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nothing gonna light a fire faster than a
big return what's the big return we
worked on it yesterday whoever catches
it everybody else in front of them and
block like crazy let's score points
first place block for each other run hit
everybody have fun turn on three with
everything that's happened we are the
family that that sports brings together
on the field we like having fun and off
the field stuff happens and it brings
you together so we always try to look
out for each other instead of letting it
divide us I want to be known in the
community as a teacher as a coach as a
father I want to be known as that person
I didn't need to get shot for that to
happen moving forward this year's begun
I've got a great group of kids the trust
is there I know some teachers they're
still struggling with it but it's a
chapter of my story now it won't be
separated as much as I would want it to
be I'm just gonna continue to do my job
the best I can and you know everything
else will take care of itself
[Music]
[Music]
come on in yeah that's a story and it
definitely takes a lot of a lot of heart
and a lot of I mean sacrifice
I was definitely so I just wanted to
come you know so the appreciation you
say hi Jameson he plays football I think
you can tackle him Tennessee Auburn and
then Florida yeah where'd you start
playing football I started playing
football my sister took me to the park
in third grade and I wasn't good at all
I'm Clint Hill didn't work no I was
playing like left guard I was just like
the kill you just throw out there like
here's your Jersey yeah
how many places they usually bring into
the huddle
you know our quarterback is pretty good
yeah I'm wondering like so I played with
crazy and Sean would be like I see it I
had a dream about it like I see it gonna
happen just like this in there and then
I'll say what happens just like that you
like man this would be really smart
that's why I like playing office it's
like defense society you gotta
anticipate so much office is more like
you got anticipate a little bit to a
certain extent just based off coverage
and stuff but you always kind of like
got the one up
you got that control so you're a
celebrity in this town now in this town
is the keyboard yeah yeah how's that
been I mean it's it's been whatever and
people are just you know wanted to say
hi and people come over and over and
over and that's the bad part like you
can't enjoy like being regular person
and mines all tail around one event
every time I talk to somebody they
brought it up so you know what it's not
one of my favorite days okay go past it
right I said I go they imagine like what
you had to deal with I'm not a what-if
kind of person yeah so life's gonna do
what life's gonna do you can that's how
you can prepare the best she wants you
and life's gonna throw your curveball
yeah you can swing this so you can swing
it hit a home run I control what you can
control right we just gotta trust that
people are gonna do the right thing yeah
that's crazy though man appreciate you
the me yes and I'm just kicking it for a
little bit yeah
appreciate you taking time to come here
no that means a lot okay hey the talk
football is someone who understands
football and really knows football it's
something I very rarely get to do
there's a lot of fun talk about you know
the ins and outs and you know
situational stuff like that I mean I lit
up like a little kid at Christmas ride
over the door
this is Carmelo Anthony thanks for
watching to meet more heroes go to be
real bleacher report.com